deshaun Watson took the NFL by storm as
a rookie in 2017 season prematurely
ended after an ACL that he told us at
the Super Bowl that year was initially
injured against the Seahawks on a Sunday
on a Thursday in went he came back
strong last year took a bunch of hits
took the Texans to the playoffs as we
said earlier Chris he's become kind of a
forgotten man among the league
quarterbacks but could he end up being
the best quarterback in the AFC this
year considering that the conference
boasts the likes of Patrick mahomes
Andrew Luck Ben Roethlisberger Tom Brady
Philip Rivers Baker Mayfield my goodness
quarterback golden era it's unreal
I mean it truly is I mean when you're
talking about you know second level guys
of yeah I mean Nick Foles and Joe Flacco
and guys like that I mean that's when
you know you got just some unbelievable
talents but yes I mean I look at deshaun
Watson and certainly think he could be
in the conversation for like being that
guy to be the best quarterback in the
AFC without a doubt now will the numbers
justify it as far as in the arena of
public perception that'll be the really
the big question you know for me again
you know he doesn't he doesn't have the
type of offense where it's Andy Reid and
Tyree killed and Sammy Watkins and
Travis Kelce to where it's just gonna be
like the greatest show on turf and oh my
gosh look at all these plays and cool
and they're gonna throw it all over the
place no that's not the style of play
and they certainly don't have the talent
that like a guy like mahomes has to so
you know it'll be hard I think numbers
wise to maybe put them up in the class
of some of these other guys I think like
guys like luck and Big Ben in my homes
will have greater numbers but I still
think the actual player and the skillset
and the type will play and be able to
carry your team in clutch moment to make
those big plays in big moments
I think DeSean Watson that's where he's
gonna prove his worth like he has to
this point in his career and as always
there's going to be a disconnect between
statistics and actually winning football
games and it's possible if the guy who
wins the most the guy who ends up with
the one seed isn't a guy who ends up
with the the biggest numbers I mean Tom
Brady last year
a contractual adjustment done before the
season where he had five different
categories and all he had to do was rank
in the same spots as he had the year
before in those five key categories and
he didn't earn a single one of those
incentives cuz so many of the guys were
better than him but he got the one
incentive itold only matters he wins the
Super Bowl but you could have a guy
who's a great quarterback but just
doesn't rack up the numbers because
there's gonna be so many last year every
week the NFL would send out a memo to
the media touting all the touchdown
passes all the points being scored and
I'm sure they're gonna look for the same
thing and hope they get the same thing
this year there probably will be a lot
of passing yards a lot of touchdowns but
that doesn't mean you're the best
quarter Jack quarterback just because
you are racking up those kinds of
numbers know that and again I think that
goes into the broader thing again right
because it's just you know it's about
the team the style of play the support
you have around on the scheme you know
everything has to be you know you know
tinkered with in the offseason and yes
it's not always on a given year or gonna
lead itself to great stats and like with
the new england and brady you know a few
years ago they were going hey get in the
shotgun we're gonna throw it every play
brady you're the man you're the men they
change the style they'll play whether
it's through draft picks and just today
they want to change their scheme and
they realize maybe Brady's getting up
there in years
doesn't mean Brady wasn't awesome but
yeah they wanted to change things and
they wanted to become a run first team
for whatever reasons Bill Belichick
decided he wanted to do that and yeah
that can hurt your numbers that way but
certainly yeah I think you know hey
again those things have to be taken to
account and the numbers for Cam Newton
like I've talked about before too
they're never gonna always be they're
not gonna be sexy in Carolina with the
talent they have around on the offense
in which they play it's a defensive
coach so yeah that's the way it is but
doesn't mean you still can't be a
special talent or in the conversation
for the best player at your position
just because the numbers aren't there
yeah here's something that just occurred
to me we have talked so much about
defenses spending the offseason coming
up with ways to stymie Patrick mahomes
right do you think the same obsession is
going to be out there for deshaun Watson
maybe there's a benefit to being kind of
overlooked that be
tween the two guys and the AFC South
teams play all of the AFC West team so
the Raiders Broncos charters have to
deal with mahomes twice they have to
deal with the shaun watson once i just i
kind of wonder whether or not watson
lands as close to the middle of the
radar screen and they spend as much time
trying to figure out how to slow him
down league wide as we'll see teams
league wide devote to trying to slow
down Patrick mahomes and that may
actually benefit to Shawn Watson it
might yeah I don't think that you know
the target of the bullseye is not on
deshaun Watson or the Houston Texans
offense back to the to the the way it is
for the Kansas City Chiefs I would
imagine a lot of teams when you have an
offense like you did in Kansas City you
know everybody's gonna go back and
reevaluate not only one what they're
doing on offense but yeah
the defensive teams are gonna evaluate
their defensive side of the ball four
teams that might be playing in Kansas
City in 2019 they're gonna go back and
go okay let's evaluate Andy Reid's
offense let's see some of the tendencies
mahomes has you know let's write that in
the scouting report so we kind of have a
base level of things we know and what to
expect when we play them in week eight
or week ten or whatever it may be you
know with the Houston Texans though I
don't think they'll be quite that you
know you know dictionary of knowledge
out there as far as the AFC or teams on
their schedule and I think teams in
their division Mike like the AFC South
they certainly went back and probably
have evaluated the Texans offense
thoroughly for a week or two in the
offseason and went through deshaun
Watson and some of his tendencies where
he likes to scramble where he likes to
look when he does scramble all of those
things and I think that's certainly
something teams have probably studied
his tendencies on it really is amazing
how top-heavy the AFC is just with great
teams and with great quarterbacks and as
we've said and this is one of the
reasons why it's so hard to rank the top
10 just be happy to be in the top 10
there are so many great quarterbacks
right now in the NFL we should
appreciate this error because I don't
know how much longer it is going to last
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports